WAHHWOAHWAAA
Hello Everyone, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Sleeping Dawn.
Now this is a horror game set inside of a procedurally generated maze and at first
I thought it was just single-player, but apparently you can play with up to three of your friends for a four-player horror experience
But before I do that I'm gonna play the single-player, and if it's too difficult
then I'm gonna ask my friends to join me in a later episode if it's good enough if it's not good
Then it's it's fine, but I actually read up on the multiplayer~
Okay, I am very sorry for whatever I've done
Whoa help your wounded friends. I was just saying I would have gotten my friends out here.
Oh, oh
Do not make hi- noise hit him *chuckle* hit him with a stick! Use the light keep watching, or do not try to- oh
Oh, o- oohh.
Ahhhh. Ahhhh.
I'm supposed to be pret- I got a hittin' stick, YEAH.
a hittin' stick- Oh.
*reading* Dodge it three times.
*chuckle* I don't know what you want me to dodge, but it's not gonna work
They can see you. Who is they? They? YOU can see me? God dammit! Alright anyway. I guess that's- oh *chuckle*
*mark being silly*
nice winky face ;)
*laughing* what the hell?
They're too strong but you have to find them and activate the lever after the levers find the exit.
Alright. Wait, what?
Down, up, up, down
OH! I gotta get two! Two levers, man- whoa.
Alright. Okay then.
But I gotta- I gotta find two. Alright, picked up an item.
Uh, picked up an item. I'm guessing- I'm guessing if you were playing four players, you could have uh,
Multiple options. Oh can I draw? Please tell me it's so. Oh *laughing*
Just an X, though? Oh come on.
Aw, fine alright fine then. Okay alright, I'm ready. I think.
Ooo, very bright. What's my bag of smoke?
Oh
It's bag of rocks - it's a bag of rocks, I should have known-
AH SQUONK
Whoa oh, oh hi, oh uh ah, oh, okay, alright.
I don't know what the bing bongs' all about. Hey how's it going? Hi friend?
*screams* Oh I'm dead, aren't I?
I *screams some more* am already dead.
*laughs pathetically* I was in the game for two minutes.
That didn't go well at all.
I'm gonna try that again, something tells me
I'm gonna need friends with this one. Alright get up. Get up! Come on get up, we gotta go!
Hurry!!!!
Alright, let's see what we got. Get my hittin' stick. Get 'em with that. Okay, I think that was that guy avoi- Oh *chuckles*
See I didn't I didn't look for that one. I didn't see that. I would have known if I had seen.
Avoid his shit there. Alright, okay. Let's do this.
Leroy ja- ohhh, it's rando.
Ah, it is rando, alright I've forgotten *gets spooked* I've forgotten everything instantaneously.
I've forgotten everything.
I got a bad feeling about this.
Okay. Oooo, squooshy alright. Oh whoa. Hey whoa, okay? You know I ain't gonna go near that.
Yeesh okay. Let me just try the other way first.
Ugh, the big mannequin can go bone himself. Oh God, no! I am the one that has to bone the big mannequin.
Alright, well he's either Hitty stick man, or is he the rock thing.
Is that what he is? I don't remember quite correctly...
Oh boy, where you at buddy? There you are. Okay alright. I don't like that but...
*soft* hi-ya
Okay...
anybody?
Oh, I hate that. Oh, I HATE that.
Yeah, don't- don't do anything. Don't do anything. Okay, alright.
You still there? Okay, alright. Ugh. Squooshy. Ugh.
Ah... AHHH
AHHHH
AHhHhHH
Hey. Hey.
Who's over there?
Huh?
*rattle* Whoaaaa, no.
*weird noise* I don't like it.
Okay, all right. Okay. All right. Is that a dead end? Is that a dead end?
ah shit it's a dead end.
Of course I just had to hit an enemy first thing out of the gate in the first round
I could of been learning as I- Oh what is that?
That's new. Alright. McDonald's is nearby.
Great! Can't wait for that!
Why does it sound like someone is walking behind me?
It does that thing where the- the- tha- it puts the footsteps just behind you
And I don't like that.
Or are they behind YOU?
*grumbling and lip biting*
Oh, I'm killing time, oh jeez.
Oh what- if you- well if this isn't the way to go then which was? Whoa. That looked like a face.
Well then where the hell am I supposed to go?
Hey! Light, light, you need light right? You supposed to get light - *screams*
I don't like this! Woah, you wanna rock? I gotta rock! Rock for you?
ooo, ah. ohhh..
*awkward chuckling*
no.
Which way did you come from lady? Which way did you come from 'cause I'm about to, uh, punch you in your face.
Yeah... Whoa- ah.
Whoa ah.
I saw that! Oh, it's a bird. Okay it's fine, everybody calm down, it's a bird.
Yeah, hey hey, hey hey hey
Hey!  I saW A LADY! IS THAT YOU LADY?
*senseless grumblings*
This might be the way I came in from... not a-
Lady?
Don't mind my squooshing.
I'm just a naturally squooshy person
ai yai yai
And a rock- I didn't need to- ah sh- now she's gonna turn around. Why did I do that? That was really dumb of me.
*screams a LOT*
AH! WHOA! HIT HIM WITH A STICK.
ahhhh shit...
*sigh*
Let's go in again. Let's see if we can.. *chuckles*
maybe I'll turn down to easy and see if I fail also which I will. I definitely will, probably just reduces the time limit.
*weird whirring*
Oh- whoa, oh I get it.
Tha... that sound is me, I'm in like limbo or something like that. Yeah...
O- and I should use the chalk to mark where I'd been! I can't I-I've been here.
uhhh
AH, why? What is you? I don't like that!
What are you doing? What are you doing? What are you doing? What are you doing? What are you? What is that?
What is that? What is that? What is that? What is that?
oo oo
That's not my footsteps, I thought this was supposed to be easier!
Okay, nothing over here. Woah boy.
Okay, who's there?
Okay maybe I shou-, maybe I should read the instructions a little bit better.
Hey look, a dark, dank tunnel! And by dank, I mean literally, it's pretty green in here.
Whoa.
No.
Oh! That's just a runny away hole.
I'm getting flashbacks from Vanish. I don't know why, but I am.
Uh-oh. Gotta get in the hidey hole!
*sick tunes*
*is confused*
Alright.
Okay, all right, let me mark this down.
*usual mark noises* okay got that.
Doing pretty decently I'd say I'd say, I'd SAY but I'd be wrong, but I'm, gonna say it.
Okay, ey, I know how to do this. Oh I know what I'm doing it. Oh, I definitely know what I'm- *groans of disapproval*
*still groaning*
*screaming*
NO OH GOD!
*more screams*
I'M ALIVE!
I'M ALIVE! THERE'S ANOTHER ONE!!
*bitchbaby screams*
Oh, oh hi! *senseless ramblings of markiplier*
Oh goddamn it! *screams*
Is this the 'dodge three times' guy?
I think it might be- AH!
Ohh God okay, all right, okay, all right. Okay? Allllriiiiiighttt.
Didn't scare me at all.
*jumps* oh
Didn't scare me. I know how to beat you. Maybe. We'll see about that hmm.
Oh goddammit, of course!
Alright, I don't even know what one of these levers look like.
I came from this way, but I'm not gonna mark it off yet.
Ah yeah, this dead end.
Alright, this all dead end.
Yee, not you. Not you asshole. Asshole, asshole, asshole, asshole.
*gets spooked*
Okay, we're fine, it's fi- oh, hey how about a rock over there?
You were going- why did I do? I keep *stutters* you were going that way. Wh- why would I have done that?
Go that way. Thank you.
I thought this was supposed to be easier, this is- this is anything, but! If anything, is more!
More not easier!
Alright, I came from this way, no, not a rock.
ai yai yai yai
ai yai yai yai- what is that? What was that? Oh is that laser man?
Hey nice eyeballs- uh oh.
What're doin- Wha- what? Uh oh.
Alright, okay weird, a little weird. I will admit a little- whoa!
oh, ah!
Hey, whoa hey- AHH ROCK! NO no no no no. You didn't see nothing.
Whoo that vine is wrigley
Something tells me I don't want to die to that lady. Goddammit, I have to go that way.
Alright, well.
I'm running out of time anyway, so death is coming.
Death becoming 'round the mountain- oh.
It's hard to tell where you're looking buddy.
Can you uh? Oh thank you. Thank you, thank you, thank you. Ugh, I think I got dripped on.
uh, drooped on me. Okay this thing- there's something over there. Uh do I want to risk going by this thing?
I do. I really do. You know I do, I do.
Okay, is there a switch? A switch swatch? No? Okay, well I'm boned.
Oh boy.
*screams from spook*
hooooooookay
aaaalright
Okay....
Whoa whoa?
I see something on the top of that. Whoa! I see something on the top of that wall!
I don't like- uh oh.
Uh oh. *groans of nopes*
backing awaaay!
Backing away.
Uh oh! Hey, I'll hit you with a stick
I'll hit you! i'll hit yo- uh oh.
oh crap! crap meister! crap meister! crap meister general!
*yelling*
I'M RUNNING.
THIS IS A DEAD END!
God damn a tit! Damn god tit damn- AH DAMN TIT!
*screams* I'll hit you with a stick!
I'll hit you with a stick. So many sticks. Stick up your butt- hello lady. Would you like a stick up your butt?
i'm going- *more of his screaming* OH NO! No no no no no no no! I got a rock! Lady! Rock!
*scared yelling*
What is that all about? What is that all about? What are you- *spooks*
Oh lady, I got a rock- AHH OH! NO! OH GOD! I DON'T WANT IT!
Please, this is weird!
Okay- it got weird. You know it was scary, and then it got really weird.
Okay. Alright. Well so there you have it.
Okay, so uh?
That is uh?
That is all the time I got for Sleepy Dawn- Sleeping Dawn.
Uh, I think I want to play this with, uh, with my buddies, and I think it'll be super cool
So let me know if you want to see that down in the comments below
I'll try to get that in order soon and let me know what you think of this game
I'll provide a link to it in the description as always and thanks again for watching and as always I will see you
in the next video
Buh-bye!